this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace
check out their awesome all-in-one
platform through the link in the
description below
more on them in a bit
he was the greatest leader of history's
greatest city
way back in the 7th century bc
nebuchadnezzar ii rose from a military
background to become
undisputed king of babylon under his
watch the neo-babylonian empire would
expand across ancient mesopotamia
absorbing everywhere from syria to
ancient judea as head
of the era's undisputed superpower
nebuchadnezzar undertook great building
works creating architectural
masterpieces like the gate
of ishtar and expanding the walls of
babylon until their size became
famed across the middle east tradition
even claims he built one of the seven
wonders of the world when he created the
hanging gardens of babylon to cure his
wife's homesickness but it wasn't
just in his own era that nebuchadnezzar
had an outsized impact
as the king who sacked jerusalem and
took the jews into babylonian captivity
nebuchadnezzar remains a powerful figure
in both modern judaism and modern
christianity likewise his capital ii
lives on as a byword for decadence
a king whose name has already lasted for
millennia this
is the life of nebuchadnezzar ii
babylon's greatest ruler
about 95 kilometers south of baghdad in
modern-day iraq lie the ruins of one of
the world's most
storied cities babylon dates back to the
4th century bc
appearing in the fertile crescent of
mesopotamia at a time so distant to our
own that the word
ancient does not do it justice in its
millennia of existence it would play
host to some of the greatest figures in
history from hammurabi who propagated
one of the world's first legal codes to
alexander the great who intended to make
the city his
capital but even among these ancient
superstars one name towers above the
others like
ziggurat reaching for the heavens that
name is nebuchadnezzar ii
because he was born so long ago so long
that the length of time separating him
from julius caesar was
greater than that separating you from
william shakespeare little information
survives about nebuchadnezzar's early
life
we're fairly certain that he was born
before 630 bc
with one common estimate placing his
birth circus 634 but since he doesn't
actually appear in the historical record
prior to adulthood
this is mostly just guesswork we're on
firm aground with where he was born
nebuchadnezzar came from
chaldea a region to the far south east
of babylonia interestingly he wasn't
actually called nebuchadnezzar that
version of his name comes by
acadian and just happened to be the one
recorded in the bible
in chaldean he was nabokodura usur which
translates to something like
naboo preserve my firstborn son the
parent asking for this preservation was
nebuchadnezzar's father
nabo palassa it was thanks to dad that
nebuchadnezzar would grow up to become a
king at all
at the time of nebuchadnezzar's birth
babylon's days as an independent city
were far behind it
roughly a century earlier the
neo-assyrian empire had absorbed
all of babylonia and it was in the
assyrian army
that nabopalasa served as general but
while it was still the biggest kid in
the playground assyria was far weaker
than anyone realized since 668 bc the
empire had been ruled by
asha benipal whose reign was only just
about papering over the cracks
a couple of decades before
nebuchadnezzar's birth one of those
cracks had involved a rebellion in
babylon itself
then the empire's second capital after
nineveh
although ashbanipal had retaken babylon
and then rebuilt it
it's not hard to imagine resentment may
have been lingering
and resentment could explain what
happened next in 627 bc when
nebuchadnezzar was
just a child king ashurbanipal kicked
the bucket
and power passed to a guy called asha or
ballard
who should probably be known as asha
ubalsa because that's exactly what his
reign would be
no sooner was king balls up in charge of
the neo-assyrian empire then it started
to disintegrate it's various provinces
leaping overboard like
rats deserting a sinking ship back in
babylon nabopalasa saw which way the
winds were blowing and
decided to follow suit when an assyrian
delegation arrived in babylon to
proclaim the new king nabapalassa barred
them from the city
not long after in 626 bc he completed
his mutiny
by having himself crowned king of
babylonia still only a boy
nebuchadnezzar suddenly went from
son of a powerful general to literal
royalty but while this was probably
great
it was only great so long as his dad
could actually follow through on his
rebellion
you see nabapalassara just declared
himself an enemy of the greatest empire
in the region and that could only mean
one thing war
the next few years of nebuchadnezzar's
life were probably pretty sweet
as a prince he likely lived in luxury or
while receiving an education befitting a
future king one with an emphasis on
military tactics and running a
government
on the other hand he had to do all of
this with hardly ever seeing his dad
you see nabapalassa would spend most of
the rest of his life
fighting for his territory all the way
clear to 616 bc nabapalassa
ran riot across the assyrian land
sacking and
destroying cities and laying the
foundations of his own empire
but it would be under his son that the
neo-babylonian empire reached its full
extent
for now nabapalassa was still too weak
to decisively defeat his old overlords
at least he was alone around 615 bc the
babylonian king had forged an alliance
with the medes who'd
likewise jump ship from assyria three
years later their joint force overran
and sacked the great city of nineveh
reducing the empire's capital to ashes
although asha obelit managed to escape
to egypt for most historians the burning
of nineveh marks the end of the new
assyrian empire
pleasingly it coincides almost exactly
with nebuchadnezzar's own rise to power
the earliest reference we have to
nabapalassa's son dates from around 610
bc when he's noted as a military
administrator for the next few years we
know only minor things about him at best
for example britannica notes that he's
mentioned helping to rebuild a temple
dedicated to babylon city god
a ripped proto-zeus called marduk but
this semi-obscurity didn't last long
nebuchadnezzar was the son of a king
more than that of a warrior king who'd
previously been a powerful general in
his era
in his location there was only one life
path a guy like that could possibly take
nebuchadnezzar would have to go to war
the first campaign that the prince took
part in is usually dated to 607 bc
that year nebuchadnezzar followed his
father on an operation into the
mountains north of assyria where he
worked as a commander for the army
he must have done a good job of it
because the following year nabapalassa
returned to babylon
leaving his son behind to fight in no
time at all nebuchadnezzar had been
promoted to commander-in-chief
it was the beginning of one of history's
greatest military careers
like hannibal or julius caesar after him
nebuchadnezzar was just one of those
guys
who got warfare he could defeat enemies
anywhere he could
overcome seemingly insurmountable odds
to net a new victory by 605 bc
it knocked the egyptian army still
allied with king balls up on its butt
and
taking control of syria it was just the
start of a campaign of conquest that
would soon see his empire stretch from
gaza in the east
to the gulf of persia in the west but
before he could do that the young
general would
have to take care of some family
business on august 16th 605 bc
nabapalassa died in babylon when he got
the news nebuchadnezzar rushed back to
the city
tradition has it that he was crowned
king within three weeks a sure sign
of his total authority it was the
beginning of a whole new era for babylon
one that would see it go from the
capital of an upstart new empire
to the great decadent city at the heart
of the known world
no sooner had nebuchadnezzar finished
securing his position as king then he
was back in the field
determined to conquer everything in his
path it said that his plan was to claim
the world for marduk leaving
no opponent from horizon to sky while he
would never quite succeed he certainly
came close by 600 bc his army had swept
across both syria and palestine bringing
countless minor kingdoms
into the neo-babylonian fold among these
was judah with its great capital
of jerusalem it would be thanks to this
conquest that nebuchadnezzar's name
was guaranteed to go down in history as
the 6th century bc dawned it was clear
that babylon's importance was rising
engravings from this time to pick the
city it's not just the center of the
universe but basically
the whole of creation but while a lot of
states had submitted to nebuchadnezzar
that submission was dependent on him
remaining a powerful force
start to falter and their jump ship as
surely as nabapulassa had abandoned the
assyrians
and that's exactly what happened in 600
bc the egyptians dealt a near-fatal blow
to the babylonians nearly destroying
nebuchadnezzar's army
in the wake of this butt kicking plenty
of newly conquered states were all like
screw this
we're joining the egyptians and declared
independence but nebuchadnezzar ii isn't
known by history as a great warrior king
for nothing
over the next two years the king bided
his time in babylon
licking his wounds and rebuilding his
army come 598 bc he was finally feeling
confident enough
to go back on the attack one of his
first targets judea
within a year nebuchadnezzar had fought
his way back to the kingdom and
laid siege to its capital jerusalem it
fell in spring of 597 and its king
jeoichin was captured
as punishment for turning against him
nebuchadnezzar sent him into forced
exile in babylon it was the beginning
of the babylon captivity known in
jerusalem as the exile
although it's traditionally dated to
jerusalem's next fall in 586 bc
the xr really starts here with jejin
being booted out over the next 15 years
waves of deportations would see the
inhabitants of the jewish kingdom
rounded up and sent away from judah to
live under close watch in
nebuchadnezzar's capital today of course
such a concept conjures horrifying
images of nazi atrocities but while the
exile wasn't exactly a barrel of laughs
nor was it remotely comparable to the
final solution
for one thing deporting judah's
inhabitants wasn't some unique thing
nebuchadnezzar dreamed up because
he was a it was standard
practice in his era for another not
everyone was included
in this forced exile it's estimated only
around 10 000 people were relocated
at a time when babylon itself housed 20
times as many those who were chosen came
mostly from the upper classes the
priests the craftsmen the rich
to the thousands more who remained in
jerusalem nebuchadnezzar redistributed
lands previously owned by the exiles
meaning many were better off and even
those who were carted away to babylon
had
a relatively comfortable fate the exile
class were allowed to build their own
jewish community even retaining their
religion
while some would assimilate most would
simply carry on as before
unhappy about their plight certainly but
they were alive and well
this probably explains why
nebuchadnezzar's portrayal in the old
testament
is so ambiguous unlike herod in the new
testament who's basically depicted as an
utter bastard
biblical nebuchadnezzar plays the role
of both despot
but also an instrument of god the exile
is seen as a punishment for judah for
its people straying from the path while
nebuchadnezzar's crazed conquests are
the hand of god at work in 586 bc
that hand delivered the mightiest blow
of all that year nebuchadnezzar's second
siege of jerusalem ended with the city
being sacked and the state of judah
ceasing to exist just one year later
a 10-year siege finally broke the canide
city of tyre
destroying one of the last held outposts
against nebuchadnezzar's rule but there
was more to the babylonian king than
just an
endless series of conquests with his
empire now at its height
his next step was to transform babylon
completely and if you're looking to
build an empire of your very own it's
time to start erecting your own
online palace with our friends from
squarespace
now more than ever people are getting
creative with their time they're
reaching into the savings account and
maybe starting that new business or
launching a
politics blog to share your opinion with
friends and neighbors we don't have to
do everything
the world is yours and squarespace is
the perfect web tool to help you fashion
it into whatever you like
it's the platform to use when you're
ready to get started on that web project
that you've been thinking about
are you looking to get in and out quick
without thinking too much about what
your website should look like use one of
their quick and beautiful templates to
make a website that's fresh
and for you very easy to make or maybe
you're more of a hands-on person and you
have lots of opinions and ideas about
how exactly you want your site to look
well squarespace gives you all of the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical
bs to worry about once you're done
setting up your website tinkering with
the design if you're so inclined or
maybe just messing around with the
colors
there are so many extra features that
squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member-only areas analytics commercial
options 24 7 customer support
it's everything you could ever want all
in one place and look this isn't just
another advertiser partnership for me
when i launched our website for mega
projects
last year i went straight to squarespace
and i used their platform to create this
elegant
super functional website it was very
easy nothing to it megaprojects.net if
you want to check that out so when
you're ready to get started on the next
project of yours big
or small if it involves a website it's
gotta be squarespace right now you can
go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch your new
site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain and let's get back to it
if you were a successful warrior king in
ancient mesopotamia
one of the big items on your checklist
was to do a ton of building then leave
giant stone inscriptions bragging about
it nebuchadnezzar was no slouch in that
department
across his reign he transformed the
faces of 13 cities but his passion
project
was wear it out to nearly everyone who
came before or after him it was
nebuchadnezzar
who'd take the mere brick and clay city
of babylon
and turn it into a place of legend
although the king did plenty of stuff
like having temple spruced up new
roads laid and palaces built it's really
three construction projects that
cemented its reputation
well maybe four but you'll see what we
mean by that in just a moment the first
and smallest of these was rebuilding
etimonaki a giant ziggurat dedicated to
marduk etta menarche
towered over the city standing 60 meters
high it rose in six
terraces topped with a great temple that
earned the complex the name
temple of the foundation of heaven and
earth because of its name
and its incredible size something the
ziggurat was the inspiration for the
biblical tower of babel
betta menarche was just a rebuilding
project one nebuchadnezzar had inherited
from his dad
his next great work would be all his own
the ishtar gate
was the eighth city gate constructed in
babylon but what it lacked in
originality
it made up for in colossal scale
standing at 11.5 metres with doors made
of huge cedar beams the ishtar gate
was a monster its brick walls were
inlaid with enameled tiles that glowed a
deep cobalt blue
yellow lions dragons and bulls decorated
the bricks in alternating rows possibly
plated with gold honoring the babylonian
goddess of among other things
war and sex the gate was designed to
slap anyone approaching the city around
the face
with evidence of nebuchadnezzar's might
and it was only the beginning
as those heavy cedar doors swung open
they revealed not just a regular entry
road but the vast grandeur
of the processional way running in a
straight line for nearly a kilometer
into the city's temple complex the way
was paved with yellow and red stones
each inscribed with
individual prayers dedicated to marduk
like some grand parisian boulevard
its sides were a full 21 meters apart
flanked by huge sturdy walls
each standing 15 meters high like the
ishtar gate the
tops and bottoms of these walls were
decorated with blue tiles
but the adornments here went even
further statues of lions and bulls
forged from gold line the route 120 of
them all
gleaming in the bright mesopotamian
sunlight flowers decorated the defensive
walls themselves so wide that
it was said that you could race two
chariots along their tops
the overall effect of the gate and way
together must have been staggering like
stepping into a dream certainly
nebuchadnezzar thought so
we know this because he left behind a
carving boasting i
adorned them with luxurious splendor
that people might gaze on them in wonder
and wonder they did although they would
be replaced on the official list many
versions of the seven wonders of the
ancient world included the ishtar gate
and
the walls of babylon aside the pyramids
and colossus of rhodes
in all honesty those long-dead writers
should have just included the entire
city as nebuchadnezzar's construction
projects transformed its face babylon
became
a kind of paradise on earth perhaps the
most aesthetically pleasing city to have
yet existed it was also likely the
biggest although
no one knows for certain it's estimated
that nebuchadnezzar's babylon was
at that time the only city on earth with
a population over two hundred thousand
yet for all his achievements the king's
greatest project may not have even been
his own it's time to talk about the
fourth great work attributed to
nebuchadnezzar and the most
controversial of all
the hanging gardens of babylon
as romantic tales go the story of
nebuchadnezzar and amitus takes
some beating a princess of median
origins today corresponding to northern
iran
amitus was married to the babylonian
king and moved to his capital
but once there the flat arid plane so
different to
the mountains of her home began to make
her homesick to lift his wife's spirits
nebuchadnezzar undertook one of the
greatest feats of engineering the world
had ever seen
laid out on beams supported by thick
stone columns the hanging gardens of
babylon were considered by the ancients
to be
one of earth's marbles on a technical
level the ancient greek writer diadorus
records the work that went into
providing the trees somewhere to grow
the beams consist of a layer of reeds
laid
in great quantities of bitumen over this
is laid two courses of baked brick
bonded by cement and
as a third layer a covering of lead to
the end that the moisture from the soil
might not penetrate beneath
but creating the beams themselves wasn't
even half the challenge the beams rose
in terraces each layer home to some
new type of plant life imported from
amateurs homeland that meant water from
notoriously flat babylon had to not just
be channeled from the euphrates
but somehow sent upwards in defiance of
gravity per diodorus this was done
using machines which many have taken to
mean an archimedes screw albeit one
predating archimedes by several
centuries
these machines were hidden from view
allowing visitors to walk through shaded
stone hallways and
relax in the gardens without ever
knowing how they were created it's a
fascinating description one that
eventually got the hanging gardens
included among the seven wonders of the
ancient world
but there's a bit of a problem with it
archaeologists have never uncovered any
evidence that the gardens
ever existed the earliest accounts
stayed from about 200 years after
nebuchadnezzar died with
no inscriptions dating from the king's
time featuring him
bragging about them and that's a bit of
a problem because nebuchadnezzar was the
kind of guy who would carve an
inscription
bragging about doing an incredible poo
the east india house inscription named
after the place where it was originally
displayed
is a massive stone tablet written by
nebuchadnezzar that lists all of his
achievements
notably there's no mention of the
hanging gardens of babylon while some
think the gardens never existed
a newly emerging view is that they were
real but falsely attributed to
nebuchadnezzar writers in the
greco-roman world generally had a
knowledge of geography on par with your
facebook addicted uncle's knowledge of
epidemiology
it's sketchy at best anything that came
from nebuchadnezzar's corner of the
world they called babylonian
even if it was assyrian and assyria is
exactly where the real hanging gardens
may have well hung the annals of the
assyrian writer sarah cherub who
reigns in nineveh from 704 to 681 bc
include his own inscription boasting a
high garden imitating the amanus
mountains i
laid out next to the palace with all
kinds of aromatic plants
meanwhile a relief dating to the time of
his grandson ashabanapol whose death
kicked off nabapalassa's mutiny back in
the first chapter
shows a king standing trumpetly amid
what appears to be
a raised possibly tiered garden add to
this senecara's reputation as a great
engineer capable of building vast
aqueducts and
cleverly directing the flow of water and
it starts to look like babylon's hanging
gardens were actually nineveh
but the idea of one of the ancient
wonders of the world being misattributed
to nebuchadnezzar isn't far-fetched when
you really think about it
he was one of the great kings of his era
the sort of world
straddling figure all sorts of legends
naturally collected around
so let's take a quick look at another of
them
if you paid attention in sunday school
there's likely one image you have of
nebuchadnezzar
as the dude who went loco in the book of
daniel in daniel chapter 4 verses 25 to
30 a voice from heaven tells the
babylonian king
that he will go mad for seven years
shortly after nebuchadnezzar's mind
snaps and according to the bible he
was driven away from people and ate
grass like the ox
his body was drenched with the dew of
heaven until his hair grew like
feathers of an eagle and his nails like
the claws of a bird
seven years later his sanity is restored
immediately afterwards
he praises the hebrew god
nebuchadnezzar's madness is a classic
biblical image famously painted by
william blake and
one of the great legends of antiquity
but is it historically true from what we
can tell
the answer is well probably not the
records we have of nebuchadnezzar
mention no period of
living out hugh cow fantasies it seems
more likely that the writers confused
the king for one of his successes now
nobodynus who
was said to be eccentric although even
he isn't known to have suffered anything
like the breakdown recorded in the bible
likewise it seems unlikely that
nebuchadnezzar ever praised the hebrew
god he was far too busy doing things for
the glory of babylon's own deity marduk
for the last few years of his long reign
this would be enough the twilight of
nebuchadnezzar's years was spent doing
what he'd always done
building and conquering in the latter
category he led an attempted invasion of
egypt around 568 bc which we know about
today from
fragments of cuneiform tablets in the
former were the great schools and
temples he funded in babylon allowing
his capital to turn into a thriving
intellectual center
and thrive it really did under
nebuchadnezzar babylon became a place of
tolerance one that respected
other gods and faiths the arts reached
new heights science was advanced there
was
even a smattering of progressivish
politics such as women being viewed
equally
under the law to men although just to be
clear this is a long long way from
anything we would consider to be equal
rights
still it was a solid legacy to leave
behind when nebuchadnezzar died
peacefully in babylon in 561 bc
we can almost imagine it was with a
smile on his face here he was
a king who'd started life as a military
brat but one who had over the course of
his reign
expanded his father's empire and made
his capital into a city which would
echo through eternity and yet his empire
itself
wouldn't be around much longer a little
over 20 years after the great king died
another perhaps greater king
upturned mesopotamia his name was cyrus
the great
in 539 bc babylon fell before his sword
ending both the neo-babylonian empire
and the jewish exile
in the end the empire nebuchadnezzar
ruled over had lasted less than a
century
today nebuchadnezzar ii is one of those
odd figures from history who
most of us have heard of but probably
know little about when we do know more
than just his name
it's likely thanks to his association
with the old testament or
maybe his erroneous linking to the
hanging gardens in some ways this is
kind of sad to see
a great king reduced to a mere footnote
in most people's minds
and yet it also hardly matters because
nebuchadnezzar left a legacy that will
stand the test of time as the man who
turned babylon into a city of legend as
the king
who helped shape the history of the
abrahamic religions
lebanese's impact on our world was
profound in ways
we can barely begin to comprehend he may
long be dead
but when the next two and a half
millennia have passed and
all of us have vanished into the pages
of history
there will still be ordinary people who
remember this bygone king's name
and remember the city that he made into
a myth
so i hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below
if you're interested please do check our
fantastic sponsor today squarespace who
i will link to below
and thank you for watching